Nhanh tương, đừng có tương tương tương tương tương trường trời LL Việt Nam đưa ra
cho bà cáo tìm chủ mới động sản hà nội, có bố ngày 1 tăng tương.
Bà cáo của các quán này kinh nhận trong tĩ 1 năm nay,
khi trường hà nội đón nhận khoảng 5,8% khẩn hộ và 1 trong 6 tương nhà liền thuộc mới từ hôn
3 mươi dự án ở khu vực cạnh và ngoài bánh đế bà có hạ tự đăng phát triển.
LL Việt Nam cho biết 1 tương nhà ở tại hà nội năm tự,
từ năm 2019, sau đến năm 2018, sẽ tăng mạnh 1 năm năm vừa qua,
1,5% khẩn hà nội, 2,3% khẩn hà nội,
dính nhận liền thuộc đạt 1,5% khẩn hà nội,
cho khi dự đoạn từ năm 2018,
1,5% khẩn hà nội, chí đạt khoảng 5% khẩn hà nội.
Bà giá bán nhá tại hà nội, khi khoảng 6,5% khẩn hà nội,
giá nhà hà nội trong quy một năm 2018,
sau với thịnh của chính mình,
cũng thề giá bán xơ cấp chung mình trong quy mốt tại hà nội,
dùi chỉ mất cao và khoảng 50 tương về 40 tương mỗi mất của một cán hộ.
Tăng hàm lắm, phải 3,5% khẩn hà nội,
và hà nâm 1 tương về 40 tương mỗi mất của người a liên thô.
Già mì chỉ vì 1,5% khẩn hà nâm,
ngoài ra trong quy một năm nay,
lại xuất cho phải 1 bất động sản tại nhiều người nền thuộc mại ra tăng.
Phổ biến ở mất tự chiến để 1,5% khẩn hà nội,
trong xấu để ý người 2 tháng đầu.